John Franklin
Sir John Franklin was knighted for his first
two journeys of exploration to the Arctic.
Yet, his third trip to the ice would be prove
to be one of the most disastrous sea-borne
expeditions of all time. He and his 128 men
simply vanished. For nearly a decade a massive
search was undertaken. In the end though,
it was the perseverance of a wife who refused
to let go that uncovered the crew’s terrible
fate. In today’s Biographics, we discover
the real story of Sir John Franklin and his
voyage of terror.
Early Years
John Franklin was born on April 16th, 1786
in Spilsby, Lincolnshire in England. He was
the ninth of twelve children to Willingham
Franklin and Hannah Weekes. Willingham was
a successful merchant, which enabled him to
provide a comfortable standard of living for
his family.
John attended school at King Edward VI Grammar
School. He got his first view of the ocean
at the age of ten and it was at that point
that he set his mind on a career at sea. His
father was not happy with the decision as
he had a career in the church in mind for
John. Within two years, however, Willingham
had softened. He allowed John to experience
life at sea by going on a trial voyage on
a merchant ship. This experience confirmed
for John that this was the life for him.
He joined the Royal Navy at age 14. Within
a few months he got his first taste of naval
warfare at the Battle of Copenhagen.
At the tender age of fifteen, Franklin served
as a midshipman on HMS Investigator. This
ship was captained by Matthew Flinders with
the mission to chart the Australian coast.
Flinders was a cousin to John and he took
a personal interest in the training of the
eager teenager. Over the course of the two-year
expedition, he was hands on in helping the
boy get to grips with the fundamentals of
navigation and surveying.
After two years, the Investigator became unseaworthy,
forcing the crew to transfer to the HMS Porpoise
for the home journey. This ship was wrecked
on a reef 200 miles north of Australia. Captain
Flinders set off with several officers in
an open boat en route to Sydney for help.
Franklin and the remainder of the crew were
left to camp on the narrow reef, using strips
of sail for makeshift tents. Six weeks later,
Flinders was back with a rescue ship.
Upon his return from Australia, Franklin secured
a position as a signals officer on HMS Bellerophon.
He was in the middle of fighting at the Battle
of Trafalgar in 1805. He did not suffer any
wounds but the roar of cannon fire left him
slightly deaf for the rest of his life.
Seven years later, the now very experienced
twenty-six-year-old was involved in the Battle
of New Orleans during the War of 1812. He
was at the head of a party that tried, but
failed, to capture New Orleans.
By the time of the end of war against the
United States, Franklin had risen to the rank
of lieutenant. But, seeing that it was a time
of peace, there were now fewer opportunities
for promotion. For three years, Franklin struggled
to secure appointments. Then, in 1819, at
the age of 32, he was given the mission of
heading an expedition to the Arctic. It was
his first command.
To the Arctic
The two ships that were to be used for the
Arctic expedition were not naval vessels.
Rather, they were whaling ships that had been
purchased by the navy. The ship that Franklin
was to lead the expedition from was the Trent.
The other ship was the Dorothea, with a Captain
Buchan on board. The mission was to head north
in an attempt to reach the North Pole and
then take a direct line to the Bering Strait
in order to finds a Northwest Passage.
The mission was predicated on the Open Polar
Sea theory. The theory was that the sea temperature
increased between the Arctic Circle and the
North Pole. By this reasoning, once a ship
had broken through the ice sheet north of
Spitsbergen, they would be able to make it
through. Prior to the voyage, meetings were
held in which scientists explained to Franklin
and Buchan the rationale behind the theory.
Acting on this information, Franklin set himself
to making observations on the tides and currents,
the depth of the sea, terrestrial magnetism
ahd atmospheric goings on during the voyage.
The ships set off from Shetland. Prior to
departure the Trent was letting in water.
The source of the leak could not be located.
It required the men to constantly work the
pumps. Franklin tried to recruit sailors from
Shetland but many of them refused, stating
that they would go to sea on a leaking ship.
This was not a good start. It meant that Franklin
set off short-handed and with a vessel that
he could not have full trust in. The men had
to man the pump and work the windlass at the
same time. This put an inordinate amount of
pressure on the crew and some of them became
overtaken with exhaustion. It took several
weeks until the leak was finally discovered
and repaired.
In the winter of 1819, Franklin set of on
his first overland expedition in the North-West
territoriy of Canada. The party stopped off
at Cumberland House, which was a fur trading
depot on the Saskatchewan River. The supplies
that they were expecting to find were not
there. A thousand miles further on at Fort
Chipewyan they reached another supply station,
but again there were no supplies.
Rather than turn back, Franklin carried on,
though he had only a single day’s provisions.
He told the men that they would hunt and fish
to feed themselves. This was a forlorn hope
and the men very nearly starved to death.
The expedition eventually made it to the Arctic
coast. They were, however, only able to explore
500 miles before the lack of food and harsh
winter forced them to turn back.
An overland journey across the so-called Barren
lands was an unmitigated disaster. The party
of twenty-two men stumbled through uncharted
territory in a state of near starvation. For
days on end, all they had to eat was lichen.
Eleven men died, with the others being rescued
by Copper Indians who helped them get to the
safety of Fort Enterprise.
Back in England, Franklin was given a hero’s
reception. He was lauded for the courage he
had displayed during adversity, becoming known
as the man who ate his boots for his resorting
to chewing on his boot leather while in a
state of starvation.
After recovering from the ordeal of his first
command, Franklin met and fell in love with
a girl by the name of Eleanor Anne Porden.
In 1824, they had a daughter, Eleanor Isabella.
In February, 1825 Franklin set out another
overland journey. This time he planned to
follow the course of the Mackenzie River to
the sea and then explore the coast. A week
after he left his wife Eleanor died of tuberculosis.
Franklin had no knowledge of the tragedy and
faithfully wrote letters to his wife until
April, at which time he read of her death
in a newspaper.
Despite the personal tragedy, Franklin’s
second voyage was far more successful than
his first. He returned to England in 1827
to much acclaim. The following year he remarried.
His second wife’s name was Jane Griffin,
who had been a friend of his first wife.
Franklin was knighted in 1829 to recognize
his arctic exploration work. During these
years on land he put on a substantial amount
of weight, perhaps in compensation for his
years of starvation on the ice. From 1830
until 1833, he commanded the HMS Rainbow as
it patrolled the Mediterranean during the
Greek War of Independence. Then, in 1836,
he was made lieutenant governor of Van Diemen’s
Land in Australia. Today this is known as
Tasmania.
Franklin enthusiastically threw himself into
the task of reforming the island. But he was
stifled by colonial infighting. His colonial
secretary, John Montagu seemed to undermine
every move that he made. Eventually he sacked
the man. Montague complained to the British
Prime Minister who agreed that the dismissal
had been unlawful. The decision was made to
recall Franklin. However, the situation was
handled badly with the replacement lieutenant
governor arriving in Tasmania four days before
Franklin had even been informed of his dismissal.
A deeply frustrated Franklin arrived back
in London in June, 1844. The timing was fortuitous
as the British Admiralty was planning another
Arctic expedition. From the moment he heard
about it, Franklin was desperate to lead it.
He felt that he was extremely qualified for
the job on the basis of his two previous expeditions.
The Admiralty agreed and Franklin was officially
appointed to command the two ships that were
to undertake the mission. They were called
the Erebus and the Terror.
On the strength of Franklin’s previous Arctic
expeditions, only about 500 kilometers of
Arctic coastline remained unexplored. This
latest voyage was designed to complete the
task. The command of the Erebus was given
to Captain James Fitz James. Command of the
Terror was given to Captain Francis Crozier,
who had commanded they ship on a previous
voyage to the Antarctic between 1841 and 1844.
The 59 year-old Franklin was given overall
command.
Both ships had been recently outfitted with
new technology. The innovations included steam
engines, a library boasting more than a thousand
books and three years’ worth of preserved
and tinned food supplies.
The expedition set sail from Greenhite in
England on May 19, 1845. In total there were
24 officers and 110 men. They headed north,
picking up supplies on the Orkney Islands.
They then set a course for Greenland. They
were escorted by the HMS Ratttler and a transport
ship named the Barretto Junior. Next stop
was Disko Island, in Baffin Bay off the west
coast of Greenland. Here five men were sent
home on the support ships due to illness.
This brought the final crew number down to
129.
The two ships and the men onboard were last
seen by European’s on July 26, 1845. On
that day, the whaler Prince of Wales came
across the two ships alongside an iceberg
in Lancaster Sound, between Devon and Baffin
Islands.
What happened after that is a matter of speculation.
It is thought that the winter of 1845-46 was
spent on Beechey Island in Nunavut, Canada.
The two ships became stuck in the ice just
off King William Island some time in September,
1846. They never got free.
The Search Begins
By early 1847, Franklin’s wife was growing
increasingly concerned at the fate of her
husband. Two summers had come and gone, which
was the length of time that Franklin had told
her he would be away. A naval officer offered
to lead an expedition to search for the two
ships but the admiralty replied that they
had
‘unlimited confidence in the skills and
resources of Sir John Franklin’.
As a concession, however, the admiralty did
offer a reward to any whalers who could report
any information about the progress of the
expedition through Lancaster Sound.
Meanwhile an old friend of Franklin’s by
the name of John Richardson made his own plans
to mount a search party. He knew that the
expedition’s food resources would run out
in the summer of 1848. He planned an overland
journey to the sea between the Coppermine
and Mackenzie rivers. This was in the case
that Franklin had made his way down the North
American coast. Teaming up with a group of
men from the Hudson’s Bay Company, Richardson
headed down the Mackenzie River to Coronation
Gulf in the summer of 1848. They found nothing.
Back in England, the Admiralty was starting
to get worried. With no news of the Erebus
and Terror by the autumn of 1847, they prepared
to send out their own search parties. In January,
1848, two ships set out – the HMS Plover
under a Captain Moore and the HMD Herald under
a Captain Kellett. They headed for the Bering
Strait to explore whether or not the two ships
had become stuck near the western exit to
the Strait. Two more ships, the Enterprise,
under Captain John Ross’ headship and the
HMS Investigator under Captain Bird headed
out in June, 1848 to go into Lancaster Sound
from the east in an attempt to follow Franklin’s
tracks.
These moves were not enough for Jane Franklin.
She wrote letters to the US President and
the Russian Czar asking them to help in the
search operation. She also set a larger reward
for whalers than had the Admiralty. She even
made plans to buy her own ship and commission
her own expedition.
Hope was raised when the captain of a whaling
ship reported that the Inuit Indians had spoken
of four ships that were frozen in the ice
in a channel south of Lancaster Sound. But
when the Investigator and Enterprise returned
having seen nothing in that area, the claim
was dismissed.
Further searches were sent out by the Admiralty
in 1850. The HMS Investigator and the HMS
Enterprise set out again, this time to search
both ends of the Northwest Passage. They joined
the Plover and Herald which were still searching.
Four more naval ships were sent to Lancaster
Sound. The ships had balloons onboard that
were let loose over the ice with notes attached
to tell the missing men, if they were still
alive, that help was on its way. Bu this time
the crew would have sent five winters on the
ice, so the belief that any of them were still
alive was optimistic to say the least.
Private expeditions were also sent out to
join in the search. A number of ships came
together at the entrance to Wellington Channel
between Cornwallis and Devon Islands. Finally,
at a distance of about 230 miles from the
entrance to Lancaster Sound from Baffin Bay
they found something. At Cape Riley on Beechey
Island the remains of the 1845-46 winter camp
was found, along with the graves of three
men.
Two American ships, Advance and Rescue, joined
the search in 1850. They both got trapped
in ice and drifted for more than a thousand
miles out of Lancaster Sound, finally breaking
free in 1851.
Lady Franklin was greatly buoyed when she
received news that the winter camp had been
founds. But she was crushed when the search
party was aborted due to an early autumn freeze.
She now directly contacted a Hudson Officer
named William Kennedy, who agreed to mount
a search with Lieutenant Joseph René Bellot
of the French navy as second-in-command. This
expedition set out in the summer of 1851 but
found no traces of either the ships or any
more camps.
Various searches continued through the spring
and summer of 1851. As well as sending up
message balloons, arctic foxes were caught
and then releases with rescue messages attached
to their collars. It was all to no avail and
every ship returned without success.
A Wife’s Will
It was thanks largely to the constant lobbying
of Lady Jane Franklin that the Admiralty continued
to mount the search after six years. Lady
Jane also stirred up public sympathy for the
plight of her husband and his crew. The Admiralty
agreed to send out a final search expedition
in the spring of 1852. It was to be commanded
by a Captain Belcher and consist of the Resolute
and the Assistance, along with the steamers
Intrepid and Pioneer. Assistance and Pioneer
headed north up Wellington Channel while the
Resolute and Intrepid headed west. A supply
ship, the North Star, waited at Beechey Island.
Meanwhile, the HMS Investigator, which had
set out in 1850, had not returned. Then, in
April, 1853 an overland party from the HMS
Resolute crossed Melville Sound and came across
the Investigator trapped in the ice in Mercy
Bay on the north coast of Banks Island. The
men on board were starving to death. The rescue
arrived just as the Captain was about to send
out a desperate party on a one-thousand-mile
trek to a Hudson’s Bay Post on the Mackenzie
River in search of food.
Finally, in 1854, a Scottish Explorer by the
name of John Rae discovered the fate of Franklin
and his men. Rae was surveying the Boothia
Peninsula on behalf of the Hudson’s Bay
Company. It was there that he was given the
story of the explorers by Inuit hunters. They
story was that the ships had become stuck
in the ice. The men on board couldn’t get
free and so headed out on foot to find a way
out. They had fallen victim to either starvation
or the cold. The Indians also told Rae that
some of the men had given in to cannibalism.
Then, in 1855, another Hudson’s Bay man
by the name of James Anderson cam across one
of the boats from the Terror at the mouth
of the Great Fish river. Some Inuit then showed
him items that could have only come from the
Terror and the Erebus.
In January, 1854 the Admiralty declared that
the members of the expedition were to be assumed
dead. Their wages would be paid to their relatives
up until March 31st of that year. Lady Franklin
would not accept this finding. But, after
so long, she was now out on a limb. The London
Times editor wrote that to continue the search
would be . . .
wasting time upon a search for dead men’s
bones.
It was now up to Jane Franklin to find the
truth about her husband’s fate. She bought
a schooner-rigged steam yacht called the Fox
and put in command of it an experienced Arctic
officer named Leopold McClintock. With 25
men, McClintock set out to cross Baffin Bay
in the summer of 1857. However, the ship spent
the winter drifting into the ice. In early
1858, the Fox entered Lancaster Sound and
made its way toward Prince Regent Inlet past
Fury Beach to a point near Bellot Strait.
During sledging operations in early 1859,
McClintock came across a group of Inuit who
had items that must have belonged to the missing
men, including snow knives. Then in a village
not far from Matty Island, he purchased silver
spoons and forks that were engraved with Franklin’s
initials. The Inuit told him of a wreck that
was four day’s journey away.
McClintock and his men headed to the south
of the island. There they found the body of
a man dressed in a steward’s uniform. Then
a 28-foot boat was found, mounted on a sledge.
The boat was laden down with clothing and
other gear, including 20 kg of chocolate.
There were also two skeletons onboard.
The Fate Revealed
At the northern tip of King William Island,
the searchers found a campsite, which they
named Camp Felix. Half way between the boat
and the camp, two piles of stones were found,
one to the north and the other to the south
of a bay. Here were found single page records
of what had happened to the crew.
The notes were both written by James Fitz
James in May, 1847.
One of them read as follows . . .
April 25 1848 — H M Ships Terror and Erebus
were deserted on the 22nd April, 5 leagues
NNW of this, having been beset since 12th
September 1846. The officers and crews, consisting
of 105 souls, under the command of Captain
F.R.M. Crozier, landed here in Lat. 69° 37’
42” N, Long. 98° 41’ W. This paper was
found by Lt. Irving under the cairn supposed
to have been built by Sir James Ross in 1831,
4 miles to the northward, where it had been
deposited by the late Commander Gore in June
1847. Sir James Ross’ pillar has not however
been found, and the paper has been transferred
to this position, which is that in which Sir
J. Ross’ pillar was erected. Sir John Franklin
died on the 11th June 1847 and the total loss
by deaths in the expedition has been to this
date 9 officers and 15 men.
The Fox sailed back to England, having at
least discovered the fate of the husband of
their patron. When the items that they brought
back from the condemned crew were displayed
in Whitehall, it aroused great interest.
Leopold McClintock received a knighthood for
his efforts in the search for Franklin and
his men. Yet it would take more than a century
and half before the two ships were finally
found. In 2008 the Erebus was found. Eight
years later the Terror was rediscovered to
the southwest of King William Island. The
ship was in pristine condition.